did you know that crab needed to be
replaced because his actor was facing
legal trouble and that Genevieve gaunt
moved on to a role you may know this is
every Harry Potter character who was
recast crab was there from the beginning
when we read about him Draco and Goyle
fighting against Harry Ron and Hermione
in the room of requirement we couldn't
wait to see that moment on the big
screen but wait that isn't crab in the
movie who is that well to understand
what's going on here the first thing you
need to know is that Krabs actor Jamie
waylet was arrested in 2009 for
possession of an illicit substance
and this cost him his role in the movies
but Warner Bros decided not to recast
him instead replacing crab with blaze
zabini whenever he was needed from that
point forward wow imagine if they just
had other teachers step in for
Dumbledore when they needed to recast
him Richard Harris Enchanted our
childhoods with his heartfelt take on
Dumbledore it does not do to dwell on
dream
when Richard was diagnosed with
Hodgkin's lymphoma around the release of
the second movie he told the director
Alfonso coron not to recast his part and
yet only a few months later Richard had
passed away Alfonso spent months
searching for the perfect actor and he
found him in Michael gambin Michael
swore that he wasn't going to just copy
what Richard had done before giving us a
performance that was definitely
different though not always to every
book fans liking
fire but if you're liking what you see
in this video we'd recommend subscribing
to our Channel still Michael's version
of the role has become iconic just like
the child star in our next role grew up
to be you may recognize the first
actress to have played pansy Parkinson
her name is Genevieve gaunt and she's
gone on to enjoy quite the acting career
appearing as Willow on the Royals does
your grandmother really kill someone but
if you go back to the Prisoner of
Azkaban you can see Genevieve fawning
over Draco after after he's hurt his arm
plus a few scenes standing amongst the
crowd her time on Harry Potter was brief
though as she'd later be recast with
Lauren shotton and then Scarlett Byrne
who is the only actress lucky enough to
actually speak at any point in the
movies someone grabbed him it seems
being elevated to a speaking role causes
a lot of recasts you'd probably remember
lavender Brown best for the time she
dated Ron in the Half Blood Prince
even asking for me she's being played by
actress Jessie cave here but this isn't
actually the first time we've seen
lavender she appeared in the background
of Chamber of Secrets being portrayed by
Kathleen Cauley and we saw her again in
Prisoner of Azkaban as actress Jennifer
Smith this recast actually caused a big
disturbance in the Harry Potter fandom
with some accusing Warner Bros of
whitewashing it does seem a little
strange that they brought Jessie cave in
right at the point when lavender became
important but it's not as strange as our
next entry have you ever wondered who
the actor playing Lord Voldemort was in
the first movie his name is Richard
bremmer and he had his face transformed
with makeup and special effect to make
it look as though he shared ahead with
Professor quarrel
when it came time for Voldemort's big
reveal and Goblet of Fire however Warner
Bros chose to go with an actor who was a
little more recognizable for the role
and so the next time we saw him he was
being played by Rafe finds things have
changed the worst part of this scene
losing Cedric Diggory
such a handsome boy don't touch him
Robert Pattinson's stole our hearts as
Cedric Diggory are you serious he took
on the role when Cedric became a
competitor in the tri-wizard tournament
in the Goblet of Fire but this wasn't
actually the first time we'd see his
character pay close attention to the
Quidditch match that Gryffindor plays
against Hufflepuff and Prisoner of
Azkaban the one where Harry falls off
his room do you see the Hufflepuff team
Seeker that's Cedric being portrayed by
stuntman Joe Livermore War Warner Bros
decided to bring in a more experienced
actor when Cedric became a more
important part and so they cast Robert
instead plus he was British it may not
sound like much but as our next entry
proves it's important here you will
rarely see a role in Harry Potter go to
an American actor Vern Troyer was the
exception cast to play the goblin Banker
grip hook in the Sorcerer's Stone but it
may be worth mentioning that griphook's
voice and does Mr Harry Potter have his
key had been provided by Warwick Davis
who played Professor Flitwick when
griphook became more important in the
Deathly Hallows part 1 and 2. Warner
Bros chose not to bring Vern Troyer back
but to have Warwick day this take over
the role entirely that probably makes
sense since Warwick was doing the voice
already and speaking of characters with
amazing voices these were two entirely
different versions of the character
Elizabeth Spriggs played the fat lady in
the Sorcerer's Stone and although she's
only had one line
she's best known for portraying matronly
types Chris Columbus first saw Dawn
French in a Harry Potter spoof for
charity
no I can't I'm filming and though she
was absolutely hilarious he brought her
in to take over the role in The Prisoner
of Azkaban
knows as as well as Domo Gleason
sometimes it's all about being in the
right place at the right time Bill is
easily the coolest Weasley you almost
forgot about we first see him in a group
photo of all the Weasleys standing
together in Prisoner of Azkaban
portrayed by actor Richard fish we don't
see Bill again until the Deathly Hallows
part 1 where he's been recast as Mad Eye
Moody actor's son Domo Gleason he was
just visiting his dad on the set which
is amazing because I was a huge Harry
Potter fan you know and I was like
when he was asked to serve as a stand-in
because I looked so much like the
Weasley twins this led to him getting
the job shortly afterward yes this isn't
the only time they didn't realize how
important a character was going to be
later on if it weren't for Helena
Ravenclaw Harry would have had no way of
defeating Voldemort she told him where
to find ravenclaw's lost diadem even
though before that we'd only known her
for haunting the halls of Hogwarts as
the gray lady Nina young was the first
brought into the role in The Sorcerer's
Stone but when it came time for her to
save the day and definitely Hallows Part
2 Warner Bros decided to cast a more
experienced actress in Kelly McDonald if
you faced a bogart what would it become
you may remember parvatis for
transforming into a giant snake before
she ridiculoused it into an even scarier
giant clown this scene shows Parvati
patil being played by Sitara Shah who
can also be seen sitting across from
parvati's best friend lavender during
divination class the next time that we
see her is when Harry takes her to the
eule ball in Goblet of Fire and by this
point she's been recast with shefali
chadri who isn't the only date who was
replaced for the Yule Ball she's a
legend on the quidditch field Angelina
Johnson was one of three chasers on the
Gryffindor team and you can see her
dominating the game in the first three
movies where she was played by Daniel
Tabor when Fred asks Angelina to the
Yule Ball in the Goblet of Fire however
that isn't Danielle playing her she had
actually been replaced with Tiana
Benjamin funnily enough enough only
Danielle would go on to reprise the role
after this movie you can see her in the
Harry Potter and the Forbidden Journey
ride at the Universal Studios theme
parks Katie Bell is the second of the
three chasers on the Gryffindor
Quidditch team you can see her on the
field in the first two movies being
played by Emily Dale she was sort of
left in the background for the most part
that is until the Half Blood Prince When
Katie touches a cursed necklace that was
meant to be given to Dumbledore for her
big moment Emily Dale was replaced by
actress Georgina Leonidas who's actually
gone on to have a successful career
acting on stage alphayes Doge wasn't
given a whole lot of time to shine he
was with the Order of the Phoenix when
they took Harry to 12 grimald Place
being played by Peter Cartwright but he
didn't have anything to say it wasn't
until Bill and fleur's wedding in The
Deathly Hallows part 1 that Harry
actually sat down to talk with elfius Mr
Potter by all means yeah and at this
point Peter had been replaced with with
David rile for unknown reasons do you
remember Alicia spinett she was off in
the background but never seemed to get
any lines she's best friends with Katie
Bell and Angelina Johnson and you could
often see her dominating the quidditch
field the first time we see her is
during a match in the Sorcerer's Stone
where she's played by Lila Sutherland an
actress who would already be replaced by
the very next movie in the Chamber of
Secrets we see Alicia being played by
Rochelle Douglas between legal trouble
and actual deaths there was a lot of
shuffling around to the cast of Harry
Potter which version of these characters
would you have to say that you prefer
and were there any examples that missed
your notice entirely we're all fans of
magic here so make sure to join us in
the conversation in the comment section
down below